okay question 13 part a now
part one is trivial isn't it it's it's
fine just use the factor theorem
that was okay no troubles okay part two
is where it started to get interesting
and by interesting i mean terrible um
firstly
you had to factorize okay now the first
problem emerged
when you had a lot of different
approaches to this okay because now that
you've done the factor theorem right
you know that that's a factor you also
know
that this is a factor okay so the astute
among you notice that if they're both
factors then this is a factor
right just like if 2 and 3 are a factor
of 24
that's how you can know 6 is also a
factor 24 because the product of the
factors will also be a factor
okay but here's where the um the
problems began
some of you saw okay look i'm dividing
this through right
but i'm missing all these terms here so
i better include them okay
so you wrote z to the six and then you
say well there are zero lots of z to the
five
and then there are negative eight lots
of this one then there are zero lots of
z cubed and on you went
okay now almost invariably you did
well actually you did one of two things
okay either you wasted your time
writing about 50 more terms than you
needed to or
you just got tripped over by the algebra
and the arithmetic in here
subtracting and adding and you got the
wrong remainder
and the wrong what's it called
question at the end okay so
what could we have done better
you should notice that this is not just
a polynomial in z
a better way to look at it is that it's
a polynomial
in z squared right so to make it simpler
for you so you don't get
caught up with all the um the even
powers that kind of thing the way that i
would have said it out
is i would have just made a substitution
say let u
is equal to z squared rewrite the thing
in terms of u
that's u cubed um 8
u squared 11 u and 20.
okay and then you can just do synthetic
division it falls out did any i didn't
think anyone did did they maybe one or
two no
no one did you just wasted time we know
how to do this right
what are you going to be dividing
through by z squared minus 4
right that's u minus 4. that's the
factor that i've got now
so you just slap 4 there right and then
you say
here are my coefficients 1 negative 8 11
20. okay we can do this can't we surely
okay you write the first number down now
what
multiply across then you add what do you
get
negative four you multiply across you
get negative 16 you add
negative five and as you expected zero
far out you guys wasted time here okay
u much side u squared minus four u
minus five you put it back into z
squared and then you can factorize the
thing
okay
p of u will be this times
this okay now once you get
it back into z squared okay
when you factorize this what's the pair
of numbers you're after
it looks like negative five and one
right so you've got this you've got your
z minus 2
and your z plus 2 at the front everyone
got that right
thank goodness okay then you factorize
this
and you said well that's z squared what
do we say minus 5
and z squared plus one and then you
should have packed up
and gone home but no no
let's play a game right
is it rational
is it rational no no
is it rational yeah yes
oh is it rational all
said yes all of you now
lesson for young beginners here right
you know i spent some time at sydney uni
last week right and
this week actually and i was doing exam
technique in that company
and i'm telling you tens and i say to
them
read the question read
the question and i think everyone was
just on autopilot at this stage and
they're like
well one of them will ask for real and
then one will ask for context
so off i go right this is what reading
time is for it's like you know back in
my day they didn't have reading time
they just said five minutes wimps just
get started okay
then they decided no no no no they need
to pay more attention to what the
questions are saying
let's give them five minutes use it
okay rational so that's where you should
have stopped
okay um that was what was that was a
hard alpha
okay when you went to par beta all you
had to do was do difference of squares
twice
and that was the mark and most of you
were fine of that okay a small mama if
you forgot to factorize it even then but
anyway there you go that was